el último debate antes de las
presidenciales del 24 de abril en
francia el presidente candidato de
manuel macro no perdió tiempo y atacó a
su rival de extrema derecha marine lepén
asegurando que rusia es su banquero esto
en referencia a un préstamo que la
agrupación nacional pidió para la
campaña de 2014 a un banco checo ruso y
que aún está pagando hable de un punto
preciso que tiene que ver con el
financiamiento de su partido lo que dije
es falso señor penn
sí señor marco es falso y es bastante
público entonces
yo me veo obligada a sacar este préstamo
en el extranjero si todo el mundo del
odio sabe eso lo sabe todo el mundo fui
a buscar el préstamo en el exterior
porque en ningún banco francés me quiso
conceder un préstamo nos el cambio
climático también causó choque entre los
candidatos es interesante al escucharla
es la incoherencia de la conversación
porque cuando usted habla de
y hablar del modelo económico de las
importaciones las importaciones que nos
prestan más problemas en términos de
déficit económico y en términos de
balance son es la dependencia de los
hidrocarburos y usted propuso la mayor
subvención para los hidrocarburos porque
usted quiere reducir el iva sobre estos
hidrocarburos entonces su programa no
tiene ni cola ni cabeza usted es una
escéptica del clima para nada soy
escéptica con respecto al clima
nunca pero quizás usted es un poco
hipócrita respecto al clima por eso es
que las personas no creen en su voluntad
de resolver todos estos problemas y voy
a decirle porque ellos tienen razón que
es lo peor de la ecología punitiva y
usted ha defendido cosas que son
violentas para las clases medias y
modestas de nuestros compatriotas los
enfrentamientos entre los candidatos
durante este debate dejan ver las
diferencias entre ellos y reflejan el
dilema del electorado la crom discurso
moderado busca mantener las riendas del
país tras cinco años de gobierno
mientras lepén afirma que cambiaría
radicalmente el rumbo de francia